Trying to raise family in Alaska.
Not exactly safe.
You just need to keep your eye out.
That's why I start packing a little bit
bigger gun.
We really came out here
just to follow our dream
of living the subsistence life.
If I was a brand new a rookie out
here, I'd be scared to death.
It is great living,
but it's easy dying out here as well.
All of our hands
have a little blood on them,
and if the predators
aren't out to get you, the weather is.
Okay, you're gonna want to watch out.
Are we going to build, like,
a little railing on the porch or anything?
I don't know about a railing,
but I was thinking,
so the roof will hang over right here.
We'll have two posts coming up.
I like your idea.
This is very much bigger
than your average dog house.
I want
the three bigger dogs to all be able
to fit in there together.
Olivez, come here...and
provide a space to get out of the rain,
out of the snow and out of the elements.
Should love on Olivez.
She's having a pretty rough time
getting around with all those puppies
sitting on her tummy.
How many puppies do
you think she's going to have?
Seven or five.
Seven, or five?
She's planning on a two hundred
thousand hundred.
Yeah. Yup. Too many.
All right Olivez, we got to get to work
because we're going to take the trees
that we got.
We're going to cut them the length
and strip the bark off of them,
with some draw knives.
That doesn't have to be perfect,
we just want enough off
to where the moisture
will not stay in there and rot.
You want some help.
Yes and no.
Yes and no?
Yeah. Watch.
Do you want to try?
You can always get that
with a [inaudible].
Will you turn my [inaudible] like this?
Can you skoot the, can you skoot the log
that way so I can roll it?
You can always hand her the chainsaw.
Not this time around.
To gain knowledge
as a child, of how to do adult things
that is so valuable.
Like all of these skills,
these are things that typically aren't
really taught in school.
That parts kind of hard
because its got knots in it.
Here I'll turn it
and maybe try, like this part.
Okay?
I think I got all the easy stuff
and you got all the hard stuff to do.
You're doing pretty good. I got
easy stuff. Oh, you did?
Oh Okay.
Lily is checking it out.
See where this one is?
Right there.
I went in from the side at an angle.
You see how solid that is?
That ain't moving. Wow.
This is going to be fantastic.
I like being away from people.
Like being away from modern technology.
I like to disconnect, create my own world.
Now live like people lived in the past.
All right.
Coming up to the snare line.
The first one right there.
Easy enough. It's empty.
My paycheck out here
doesn't come in the form of money.
It comes in the form of meat
and I need to find more meat.
I need to center it a little bit more.
All right.
Keep on checking.
You know, it's interesting, because I made
these paths with my snowshoes
and now I don't need snowshoes anymore
because it packs down
and it freezes overnight.
And the solution here is kind of
do the same thing.
They just go in the same exact place.
So they're making little highways
I'm making little highways.
Everything I do out here,
I'm learning from the animals.
See what's happening here?
Nothing. Trap looks good.
No new tracks at all around it.
Keep on checking.